thank you  [Music]  life changed because it was your dream  about restaurants Consulting one one  second you felt like your dream was over  yes I felt like this  [Music]  I never fetched the situation when in  your life the war happened and what was  like what should we do to to move on to  continue  one CDP Chef started to cook for a  Ukrainian military use all our products  which you have in the fridge  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  for them is to have a space where they  can like create their own menu find  their own identity so Forest is like  learning a lot of different food without  changing restaurants what is your hope  in bringing a Ukrainian Chef here to  Brooklyn if mirali is able to do what he  loves to do even if it's not in Ukraine  but somewhere else and we can help him  achieve that I think this is the first  step  yes in Ukraine there's World War but we  can also can go be creative in dark time  and here I can use energy for creating  something not for thinking about ever